there is seemingly no end in sight to
the cues and cancellations this was
heathrow's terminal 3 where the line to
the start of security was 90 minutes
long at manchester peter found his
easyjet flight was cancelled when he was
about to board he's trying to reach
paris for a friend's funeral and has
forked out hundreds to rebook
they just basically said well we'll give
you money
and
deal with it essentially like no service
is trying to help you reschedule a
flight or find other options
there's no helping desk there's
you basically you're on your own every
person had to find their own way
yeah it's just my standard kit so it's
my training stuff
aaron mckibbin should be representing
great britain right now at a para table
tennis tournament in montenegro but he
and 10 teammates had to pull out when
their whiz air flight was cancelled just
hours before departure my team you know
we have a lot of teammates that they
needed this competition you know they
need the tournament credits to be able
to compete at the world championships so
you have to you have to play a certain
amount of competitions for a year and
this was really there's only a few left
so it was important they played this but
we've also got a few players that are
not actually ranked high enough at the
moment they're not in a qualification
spot so again really important for them
after days of disruption ministers have
been meeting industry figures to try and
resolve the crisis but it seems there's
little room for progress with all sides
now engaged in a somewhat circular blame
game there's clearly
been a
a lack of preparation for that surge
back of demand of holiday makers and
grant chaps has been taught the
transport secretary has been talking to
the industry
for months now saying that this will
come and and that you need to make sure
you've got your recruitment in place the
half-term holiday combined with the
jubilee weekend has created a surge in
demand which an understaffed industry
simply cannot meet having shed jobs
during the pandemic the sector is now
struggling to fill them if you can get a
better hourly rate elsewhere and the
labour markets become more competitive
that's why you see these vacancies they
probably also cut too far you know a
number of organizations had panic
moments
at the onset of covet not all the
cancellations are last minute airlines
say the majority are being made well in
advance of passengers reaching the
airport to reduce the chaos inside but
there are deeper structural issues at
play here as a result of brexit and the
pandemic that have seen as many as
twelve thousand vacancies here at
heathrow airport alone and until those
problems are fixed the disruption is
only going to continue and the fear is
it could even get worse come the summer
it is certainly a challenge for an issue
you cannot solve short term i think one
of the things that we ask national
governments to do is to
look carefully
into these background checks procedures
because even if you hire a person
at the airport or the airline
it can take weeks sometimes months
before the background check is actually
is actually done
and as the finger pointing continues its
passengers paying the price iva bennett
sky news